why did I give him that weight for his  birthday always treat the customers  which makes no sense  Dave Dave okay David I got fired from  Chama can't be using the foot measurer  inappropriately  oh yeah  [Applause]  taking the counterpoint is former  television star Jerry Seinfeld okay  thanks Colin thanks rod buddy yeah for  your information guy I'd be doing myself  a disservice and every member this bad  if I didn't perform the hell out of it  oh yeah for again [ __ ] ain't no fun  lately over here we asked 100 mins  - the governor honest must make a choice  [Laughter]  not just any kind of snake these are  made from genuine diamondback  rattlesnakes bread